bonjour Daniel bruyet bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous pour la
première fois dans cette émission on est
ravis de vous recevoir on est ensemble
pendant une demi-heure vous êtes élus du
Val-de-Marne donc du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire vice-président
de la commission des finances du Sénat
on va évidemment parler de la réforme
des retraites dans quelques instants
mais d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu c'est
cette professeur d'espagnol qui a été
tué en plein cours par un élève à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques quelle est votre
réaction à ce moment j'ai d'abord une
pensée pour ses proches ça famille ses
collègues et puis pour les élèves je
suis moi-même papa de deux enseignants
dont une fille qui travaille dans un
lycée professionnel avec des enfants qui
rencontrent parfois des difficultés
psychiques et je voudrais dire à cette
occasion je veux pas faire que Monsieur
Darmanin proposait une loi chaque fois
qu'un événement dramatique mais je pense
que la souffrance psychique des
adolescents est en grande difficulté
dans notre pays et que peut-être ce
drame nous appelle collectivement à
regarder comment accompagner ses
souffrances et comment aussi accompagner
les enseignants qui se sentent souvent
très seuls et très démunies devant des
situations même si en l'occurrence pour
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'était assez
imprévisible s'agissant de ce jeune
homme son passage à l'acte on va parler
de la réforme des retraites puisque la
semaine prochaine le Sénat examinera le
texte qu'elle va être la stratégie du
groupe écologiste dans cet examen voilà
la stratégie elle est assez simple elle
est d'ailleurs coordonnée avec nos
partenaires de gauche d'abord nous
voulons un débat clair et nous voulons
pouvoir débattre au fond du sujet donc
nous allons amender débattre arctique
par article de de chacun des sujets qui
nous sont proposés et puis surtout
contester cette retraite qui est au fond
une retraite injuste une retraite qui se
construit de façon très peu démocratique
réformer les retraites sans aucun accord
de syndicats je mets à part le Medef
c'est quand même un exploit que personne
n'avait jamais réussi à faire dans ce
pays et utiliser des procédures comme le
47 ans ou 49-3 pour corseter aussi le
travail parlementaire tout ça ne dure
rien de bon
en tous les cas on est déjà dans un 47,1
qui est une façon de limiter la
possibilité des parlementaires on va
nous débattre pendant 12 jours d'affilée
weekend de compris et j'espère que le
débat pourrait être mené au bout et
qu'il n'y aura pas d'empêchement du
travail des parlementaires du côté de la
présidence je pense notamment du du
Sénat de veiller à ce que le droit
d'interpellation le droit de prise de
parole sur chaque amendement puisse être
respecté parce que sur un texte comme
celui-là il faut pouvoir débattre au
fond article du temps de parole en
séance
qui s'est dit dans les échanges entre
président de notre côté il n'y a pas de
volonté d'accumuler les amendements
comme ça pu être le cas
c'est encore en cours d'écriture
que la France insoumise à l'Assemblée
non très très clairement nous aurons
sûrement l'ensemble des groupes de
gauche peut-être 2000 amendements c'est
à peu près ce qui s'est fait à chaque
réforme des retraites mais par contre
nous souhaitons qu'il soit débattus les
uns après des autres et nous souhaitons
aussi pouvoir nous exprimer
individuellement chacun et parlementaire
il doit pouvoir prendre la parole sur
ses amendements on va quand même prendre
deux ans de la vie de nos concitoyens ce
texte vous savez j'étais hier avec deux
ATSEM dans ma commune d'Arcueil et elle
me disent Monsieur le Maire on va nous
prendre nos plus belles années de
retraite bon elle m'appelle encore
Monsieur le Maire c'est un reste du
passé voilà juste est-ce que vous vous
me dites je souhaite pouvoir aller au
bout du débat c'est à dire que vous
souhaitez un vote sur le texte final
jusqu'au bout du texte très clairement
on préfère que ce texte ne soit pas voté
et par ailleurs la façon dont nous
sommes nous-mêmes possiblement corseté
ne nous amène pas à choisir
à choisir d'aller au bout de ce texte
mais on veut que l'article 7 soit
débattue on n'a pas énormément
d'illusions mais on pense qu'il faut que
chaque parlementaire puisse en
conscience et devant ses concitoyens
devant les grands électeurs s'agissant
des sénateurs exprimés son choix pro
retarder l'âge de départ en retraite ou
pas sur cet article secrétaire manuel
bon parc qui est le coordinateur de la
France insoumise était à votre place et
il appelait les sénateurs de gauche à
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de vote
sur cet article 7 parce que ça serait
donné le point au gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez écoutez je suis sur
ce sujet en désaccord avec Emmanuel
Bompard nous nous souhaitons qu'il y ait
vote sur l'article 7 parce que c'est le
rôle des parlementaires de dire ce qu'il
pense au Sénat la surprise sera sans
doute fait puisque depuis des années nos
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale et
l'air propose une réforme qui ressemble
beaucoup à celle là au fond c'est une
réforme de droite et au Sénat elle sera
un peu chez elle mais nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait clarté et vote sur cet
article et nous souhaitons que devant
les manifestants je pense sur cette mars
par exemple les gens sachent qui a voté
ou qui ne votent pas cette prolongation
de l'âge de départ à la retraite sur le
fond on vous dites il va y avoir
plusieurs amendements du groupe
écologiste sur quoi vont porter ses
amendements sur tous les articles je
pense évidemment au régime spéciaux ou
par exemple je considère pour ma part
que c'est assez difficile de juger qu'il
faut supprimer les régimes spéciaux
quand nous même on en a assez
particulier donc je moi j'inviterai mes
collègues en tous les cas j'inviterai
mes collègues à la cohérence s'ils ne
veulent pas supprimer le régime du Sénat
il ne faut pas qu'il vote la suppression
des régimes spéciaux qui sont en général
oui c'est un régime autonome mais on
reçoit beaucoup de courriels des clairs
de notaire et d'autres professions qui
nous disent exactement la même chose
donc au fond souvent les régimes
spéciaux sont liés à des duretés dans le
travail je pense pour ma part qu'il y a
d'autres duretés qui devraient être
prises en compte la souffrance au
travail existe on parle de la souffrance
psychique mais il y a aussi la psychique
de plus en plus importante avec les
augmentations de productivité on met les
gens dans des tensions de plus en plus
grandes au travail et au lieu d'allonger
la durée de travail je pense qu'on
devrait plutôt comme d'autres pays
élargir la semaine de quatre jours
penser à l'organisation du travail ce
gouvernement fait tout à l'envers il est
dirigé par des pensées vraiment très
libérales et purement financière et il
faut d'abord regarder les conditions du
travail avant de vouloir étendre la
durée du travail on va parler d'un autre
sujet inquiétant c'est la France qui
connaît une sécheresse hivernale record
alarmante hier Christophe Béchu a dit
vouloir prendre des mesures de
restriction soft ce sont ces mots dès le
mois de mars vous êtes satisfait
à tous les cas je pense que c'est
incontournable et indispensable
satisfait serait beaucoup dire parce que
dans le même temps il reste une
ambiguïté sur les
usages de l'eau et je pense que ni le
gouvernement ni d'ailleurs les
l'assemblée à ce journal assez pris la
mesure de ce que veut dire vivent dans
une France à plus 4 degrés qui est la
trajectoire sur laquelle aujourd'hui
nous sommes et les sécheresses lorsque
j'étais élu voilà quelques mois j'ai
auditionné à titre personnel une
chercheuse du CNRS Florence sabetz parce
que j'étais très préoccupé par cette
question de l'eau j'ai été élue au mois
de juillet nous étions déjà dans une
période de sécheresse et cette
directrice de recherche au CNRS
m'expliquait qu'en gros dans les années
qui viennent sans doute les deux tiers
voir les trois quarts de notre pays
vivrait dans un climat méditerranéen
avec des sécheresses aggravées et donc
incitait aussi à préserver les nappes
phréatiques à préserver la qualité de la
ressource en eau
Christophe Béchu l'a dit il appelle à se
et au pire à préparer le pays à 4 degrés
de réchauffement climatique à sortir du
déni c'est la preuve qui a une prise de
conscience de la part du gouvernement
écoutez moi j'aimerais que cette prise
de conscience se traduise dans des
mesures radicales on a su être radicales
face aux covid en mobilisant des moyens
financiers très importants on ne l'est
jamais lorsqu'il s'agit de la transition
écologique ou d'une mutation pour faire
face à ces changements climatiques non
ça n'est pas qu'une question de moyens
c'est aussi une question de penser par
exemple la réforme des retraites dont on
parlait c'est une réforme productiviste
on veut toujours produire plus mais
cette planète ne peut pas produire plus
donc il faut se demander comment on
partage différemment la richesse
produite et comment on donne à chacun
l'essentiel plutôt que le superflu et ça
sera vrai dans les débats sur l'eau il
faut changer nos modèles agricoles mais
ça veut dire quoi vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure il faut sortir des
ambiguïtés concernant les usages de
l'eau ça veut dire quoi bah je vais vous
prendre deux exemples sur l'agriculture
il faut une agriculture pas irrigante
c'est une nécessité absolue donc il faut
accompagner nos agriculteurs qui en
général souffrent déjà beaucoup face à
ce nouveau défi donc pour ça il faut
mobiliser la recherche la recherche
académique il faut accompagner les
transitions vers l'agroécologie on sait
par exemple que lorsque les sols sont
plantés ils retiennent beaucoup mieux
l'eau donc les bassines qu'on nous
promet à droite à gauche ne sont pas une
solution il faut pas réfléchir à ce
stockage de l'eau mais bien sûr il faut
réfléchir au stockage de l'eau mais pour
ça il faut écouter les académies avec le
meilleur stockage de l'eau c'est celui
qui est dans les nappes phréatiques et
dans les sols donc il faut faire au
maximum en sorte que les sols soient
humidifiés et non pas qu'on stocke
artificiellement des eaux et surtout pas
en allant puiser dans des nappes
phréatiques qui ne se reconstitue pas ce
débat il doit être mené avec sérieux
avec tranquillité et avec respect de
chacun des partenaires mais on appuie
sur le travail de nos scientifiques
académiques je parle pas de d'autres
avis qui pourraient être parfois
utilitariste
travailler aussi sur la question des
eaux usées on sait que la France est
très mauvaise dans le recyclage des eaux
usées il faut travailler là dessus pour
vous il faut bien sûr travailler sur le
recyclage des eaux usées il faut pas non
plus en attendre des merveilles il faut
s'intéresser aussi à notre énergie ça me
permet de dire un mot du nucléaire j'ai
déposé par exemple un amendement qui
demandait qu'avant toute création de
nouvelles unités de nouvelles EPR il y a
une étude académique sur le niveau des
tirages des fleuves dans 20 ans on va
construire au mieux dans 15 ans des
centrales nucléaires elles utilisent 40%
de de l'eau de notre pays de nos fleuves
donc on va construire de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires et on va pas se
demander quels seront les niveaux
d'étiages et vous savez elles seront
interminantes intermittentes parce que
les niveaux d'étiages des fleuves sur
lesquels elles sont installées
indispensable au refroidissement donc on
me dit qu'on va trouver d'autres
dispositifs qui seront peut-être
énergivores toujours est-il qu'il faudra
se demander parce qu'il y aura l'été
concurrence faut-il pour produire
l'énergie laisser alimenter les
centrales ou faut-il irriguer ou faut-il
nourrir les peaux servir les populations
c'est conflits d'usage vont se
développer très vigoureusement on va
parler de la question de la rénovation
énergétique puisque le Sénat a lancé une
commission d'enquête sur le sujet pour
tenter de comprendre pourquoi la France
n'atteint pas ses objectifs ont la
matière on va faire le point sur les
travaux de cette commission avec Marion
Delpech
bonjour Marion bonjour bienvenue dans
cette émission merci grande première on
est ravi de vous recevoir Marion et
Marion avec vous on va faire le point
sur cette commission d'enquête du Sénat
puisque ces dernières semaines cette
commission d'enquête qui se penche sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation
énergétique a entendu successivement
plusieurs ministres qui étaient chargés
du sujet tout à fait Oriane les anciens
ministres devaient répondre à une
question des sénateurs et cette question
est bien c'était comment se fait-il
qu'on dénombre en France plus de 5,2
millions de passoires thermiques en 2022
cela représente l'équivalent de 17% du
parc de logement alors que de nombreuses
lois écologiques ont été votées sous
différents gouvernements ces dernières
années et ce sont d'abord Ségolène Royal
et François de Rugy qui ont répondu à
cette commission d'enquête sénatoriale
au travers de ces deux figures 10 ans
d'action publique ont été balayées en
deux heures d'audition et l'une des
conclusions de l'ancien ministre de
l'Environnement François de Rugy sur le
sujet c'est que le plus symbolique peut
parfois l'emporter sur le plus efficace
faut aussi se poser la question de
savoir si ce que l'on recherche c'est ce
qui est le plus efficace et donc de
déterminer aussi ce qui est efficace le
nombre de tonnes de CO2 économiser
chaque année l'énergie économiser CO2 ou
pas ou ce que l'on recherche c'est ce
qui est le plus symbolique en étant
resté un observer un observateur
attentif même si j'ai pris un peu de
distance avec la responsabilité
politique nationale que ce double
questionnement n'a pas changé
permettrait même de penser que
malheureusement le plus symbolique
l'emporte largement et très souvent sur
le plus efficace Ségolène Royal exprimer
quelques regrets notamment sur la
suppression du crédit d'impôt qu'elle
avait mis en place
vous savez dans des arbitrages
interministériels c'était des combats
d'obtenir un crédit d'impôt je sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte par rapport
au ministère des Finances c'est mamie
inimaginable d'obtenir un crédit
d'impôts moi comment je faisais gymener
à COP 21 comme 21 il faut qu'on soit à
la hauteur de la COP 21 il faut faire
des choses extra exceptionnelles parce
que c'est la COP 21 c'est comme ça que
j'arrive à arracher les arbitrages le 13
février se sont ensuite cinq anciennes
ministres qui ont été auditionnées sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique
écoutez les propos d'Emmanuel vargon la
ministre du logement durant le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron on peut
mettre tous les objectifs législatifs
qu'on veut on peut mettre des chiffres
dans les lois successives la loi
elle-même est pas auto-réalisatrice et
donc il suffit pas de dire que on rénove
500 000 logements par an dans la loi ou
que il n'y aura plus de passoire
thermique 10 ans après le vote du noir
pour que tout ceci se produise c'est un
sujet qui un sujet de moyen d'exécution
et de système si la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments coûte chaque
année entre 4 et 7 milliards d'euros
l'ancien ministre du Logement Cécile
Duflot dit-elle aussi avoir été
confrontée au manque de moyens elle
dénonce certaines règles budgétaires
complètement absurdes et
contre-productive l'autre frein mis en
avant si celui de la complexité des
aides pour la rénovation des passoires
thermiques et il semblerait que même
l'ancienne ministre de l'écologie
barbara Pompili étude du mal à s'y
retrouver il s'avère que moi je l'ai
expérimenté à titre personnel et que
même moi qui suis quand même plutôt
sensibilisée au sujet j'ai pas réussi à
avoir toutes les aides auxquelles je
pouvais prétendre et j'ai loupé des
trucs parce que j'ai mal rempli enfin
bon donc je me dis si même quelqu'un de
au courant comme moi n'arrive pas à
obtenir les aides vous imaginez bien des
gens qui n'ont pas la même connaissance
du sujet enfin subsiste la question de
la prime rénove créée par le
gouvernement pour simplifier le système
aide financière dégressive en fonction
des revenus accessibles aux
propriétaires pour rénover leur logement
sur 644000 projets financés en 2021
seulement 2500 sont sortis du statut de
passoire thermique le dispositif n'est
donc pas encore très efficace Daniel
broyer après les auditions des dernières
semaines de plusieurs ministres qui ont
mis en avant les failles de ce système
avez-vous le sentiment que le
gouvernement a vraiment simplifié le
dispositif d'aide et comment pourrait-il
être amélioré selon vous dans l'avenir
je vais commencer par rappeler qu'il
faut améliorer ce dispositif parce que
les passoires thermiques c'est un
problème de santé un problème financier
pour des familles souvent parmi les plus
pauvres c'est un problème d'émission de
CO2 et c'est un problème de déficit
commercial pour notre pays donc tout ça
c'est vraiment des raisons qui demandent
qu'on puisse rénover ces passoires
thermiques ensuite ce que j'ai entendu
et tiré de ses premières auditions c'est
qu'il faut sans doute une loi de
programmation financière pour créer de
la continuité et une lisibilité tous les
ministres l'ont dit c'est une bataille
avec merci permanente donc au moins en
stabilisant des crédits et en les
augmentant je crois qu'Emmanuel wargon
disait il faudrait au moins un milliard
de plus pour tenir les objectifs ce sera
un signal donné aussi aux professionnels
ensuite oui à la raison c'est un système
qu'il faut construire un système avec de
la formation professionnelle avec des
agréments avec des dispositifs aussi
d'accompagnement des familles dans la
rénovation et quelques collectivités
s'ils sont essayées mais là encore les
mesures que nous votons en loi de
finance leur demande de ne pas avoir de
dispositif de crédit de fonctionnement
dédié à ça mais il faut de l'ingénierie
pour réussir la transition c'est
pourquoi notre groupe a demandé cette
commission d'enquête parce que nous
voulons à tout prix réussir la meilleure
énergie c'est celle qu'on ne consomme
pas et c'est celle qui n'aimait pas mais
il faut que les élus vous avez été mère
vous l'avez rappelé il faut que les élus
locaux soient plus associées mais bien
sûr les élus locaux ont un rôle très
important de proximité à la population
mais les départements aussi par exemple
qui ont la responsabilité de l'aide
sociale lorsque j'étais vice-président
du justement nous avions conduit un
système expérimental pour accompagner
les copropriétés ou les locataires les
plus démunis dans ces gestes sur trois
communes tout ça est tout à fait
généralisable mais il faut pour ça de
l'ingénierie et puis il faut des crédits
et une constance dans ces crédits pas
des crédits annuels rediscutés au gré
des déficits publics on devrait
d'ailleurs retirer du calcul du déficit
public tous ces crédits destinés à la
transition écologique parce que on peut
on nous parle souvent de la dette mais
vous savez il y a une dette qui ne se
rembourse jamais c'est la dette
climatique donc celle là il faut agir
quand on parle des 4 degrés de la
sécheresse si on n'a pas compris qu'il
faut agir à une autre échelle que celle
qui est la nôtre un autre rythme que
celui qui est notre aujourd'hui c'est
quand même assez dramatique
merci Marion à tout à l'heure merci
Marion à tout à l'heure dans le club
Marion on va passer à l'actualité dans
votre département on va parler des
sénatoriales on va aller à
Nogent-sur-Marne dans le Val-de-Marne
retrouvez Cécile Dubois bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et d'actrice
en chef du quotidien en ligne 94
citoyens bonjour Cécile et Cécile vous
souhaitiez nous parler des prochaines
élections sénatoriales en septembre
bonjour Merci beaucoup de cette
invitation oui Europe Écologie Les Verts
fait régulièrement de bons scores aux
élections européennes et lors des
municipales de 2020 les écologistes ont
aussi connu un succès historique en
gagnant de grandes villes comme Lyon
Bordeaux Strasbourg Poitiers Besançon
Annecy et donc de grands électeurs les
départements de ces communes ne font
toutefois pas partie de ceux où se
tiendront les élections sénatoriales
ironie de l'histoire votre département
le Val-de-Marne qui avait contribué à la
bascule à gauche du Sénat en 2011 avec
l'élection d'une sénatrice écologiste
dans le cadre d'une liste d'union de la
gauche qui avait raflé quatre sièges sur
6 et aujourd'hui en mauvaise posture la
gauche val-de-marnaise qui avait
conservé trois sièges en 2017 perdra
mathématiquement son troisième siège en
2023 suite au conquête de la droite aux
municipale de 2020 les écologistes
perdront donc leur siège Val de Marnay
car ils comptent moins de grands
électeurs que les communistes et les
socialistes pensez-vous pouvoir gagner
d'autres sièges dans un autre
département pour compenser la perte du
Val-de-Marne et dites qu'ici entre
partie de gauche peuvent-elles jouer en
ce sens pour refléter le poids de chacun
dans la Haute Assemblée
bonjour Cécile Dubois tout d'abord
écoutez d'abord vous considérez que le
ciel du Val-de-Marne est perdu ça n'est
pas mon analyse les chiffres méritent
d'être regardés je ne sais pas quelle
sera la configuration à gauche et je ne
sais pas quel sera là où les
configurations à droite donc tous ces
éléments là vous l'avez rappelé le siège
le quatrième siège d'Esther Benbassa
avait été acquis un peu par surprise
donc moi je ferai en sorte que le plus
grand nombre de sièges puisse revenir à
la gauche et aux écologistes en tous les
cas les deux me paraissent certains mais
le troisième ne me paraît pas totalement
inaccessible et c'est dans ce sens qu'il
faut travailler et puis je crois aussi
qu'il faut élargir notre regard
c'est-à-dire qu'au fond pour avoir la
garantie des deux sièges il faut sans
doute que écologiste socialiste et
communiste s'entendent et pour espérer
en gagner un troisième c'est une
certitude mais c'est vrai aussi dans les
Hauts-de-Seine c'est vrai en
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est vrai dans les
Yvelines donc je pense que nous aurons
l'intelligence aussi de nous dire au
fond si nous facilitons l'élection d'un
sénateur écologiste dans le Val-de-Marne
et bien nous aiderons à l'élection d'un
sénateur socialiste ou communiste dans
un autre de CD départements et
vice-versa voilà c'est pour moi la bonne
démarche d'ailleurs moi je suis un élu
au fond de cette démarche d'union je
n'étais pas éligible au moment de
l'élection précédente et je me suis
retrouvé sénateur grâce à une démarche
d'union de la gauche donc je souhaite le
meilleur à nouveau pour notre
département et que nous affichons une
volonté de conquête vous êtes sénateur
depuis peu parce que vous avez remplacé
Sophie Tail et polluant qui a été élu
député en juin dernier est-ce que vous
avez envie de continuer à ce que vous
serez candidat au mois de septembre vous
pouvez le dire je suis un très jeune
sénateur et en tous les cas c'est un
travail passionnant est-ce que j'ai
envie de continuer je pense que je
présenterai ma candidature à mes
collègues dans le but de servir je le
dis aussi je n'en ferai pas du tout un
sujet j'avais avant d'être élu sénateur
choisi de quitter mes fonctions
électives parce qu'il y a une très belle
vie aussi lorsqu'on n'est pas élu mais
la vie de sénateur est passionnante donc
je réserverai la primeur de ce débat au
Val de Marnay dans quelques temps cé
cile écologiste au Sénat la gauche chez
minoritaire au Sénat et les écologistes
sont minoritaires au sein de la gauche
au Sénat dans ce contexte quel est votre
marge de manœuvre pour avoir de l'impact
dans cette assemblée est-ce que vous
avez des exemples concrets de dossiers
qui ont pu avancer grâce aux écologistes
de positions qui ont évolué grâce aux
écologistes
nous sommes effectivement le plus petit
groupe aujourd'hui nous sommes 12
j'espère bien que nous serons 18 ou 20
après l'élection qui s'annonce du mois
de septembre mais nous travaillons sur
tous les textes avec une énergie que les
autres parfois nous envie c'est une
énergie humaine et donc renouvelable
sur le texte des énergies renouvelables
très clairement nous apportons notre
regard et puis vous savez même lorsqu'on
n'obtient pas à la majorité et très
clairement à droite je l'appellerai même
assez conservatrice sur beaucoup de
sujets mais même lorsque nous n'obtenons
pas gain de cause sur des propositions
que nous avons formulées nous essayons
de de nourrir de cultiver avec les idées
de la transition écologique ce Sénat qui
a sans doute besoin sur ce sujet de la
transition écologique d'une
acculturation qui lui fait encore très
largement défaut mais il y a des sujets
on se retrouve parfois pense au
transport en commun nous avons fait
voter par exemple un amendement sur la
TVA 5 5 sur les transports en commun
c'est un sujet important mon collègue
Daniel Salman j'ai évoqué avec Renan
Dantec sur les énergies renouvelables à
obtenir des améliorations pour essayer
de faciliter ce texte amélioration
malheureusement disparue à l'Assemblée
nationale puis en CMP voilà moi je siège
à la commission des finances les
amendements sont très durs à obtenir
parce que au fond les choix libéraux du
gouvernement sont souvent aggravés par
les choix de la majorité sénatoriale
mais il n'empêche que nous faisons
entendre notre voix comme nous l'affrons
entendre sur les retraites avec l'idée
que une autre société possible une
société où le bien-être au travail et
regarder avant de regarder la durée du
travail et surtout ces sujets la voie
des écologistes et est importante aussi
rappelé que ça n'est pas par plus de
productivité par plus de production par
plus d'accélération dans le du travail
on dénonce les accumulations de richesse
vous vous évoquez totalement mais
franchement des des dizaines de
milliards de bénéfices c'est indécent
quand des gens n'ont pas de quoi se
nourrir ou de quoi remplir le plein de
leur automobile lorsqu'ils en ont un
ardente nécessité merci beaucoup Daniel
Breuillet d'avoir été avec nous merci
Cécile Dubois on regarde quelques-uns
des articles à lire sur votre quotidien
en ligne 94 citoyens merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous Cécile Dubois
excellent quotidien les articles merci
beaucoup dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on ira dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques ou une enseignante
a été tuée hier on sera avec le sénateur
de ce département Max Brisson merci
beaucoup Daniel Bruyer d'avoir été avec
nous cette invitation on accueille notre
chaîne invité c'est Jean-Louis pour
l'ange